and action I think everyone's formative
period is their teenage years for me it
was the late 70s and early 80s the music
of that period the movies of that period
I've always looked for a way to try to
address that time that was my time even
though I don't feature in the movie as a
character those memories are very
personal it's 1981 which involves quite
a lot of 1970s leftovers so there's some
fantastic costumes wandering around big
hair don't you look absolutely glorious
so I had a zoom during lockdown with Sam
he said I'm thinking of writing this
film and I'm thinking of you to play a
part in it and I said yes please and
turns out the script was really good
I thought it had real life to it it felt
truthful and the writing really
transports you into the era of the piece
wow
it's beautiful
it is Sam's director's style he's he can
communicate very very well which I love
it makes it so much easier as an actor
to not be thinking about so much things
that a director is saying
he is so emotionally engaged he knows
exactly what to say so that you
understand what he wants if it's sad
he's crying it's funny he Giggles behind
the monitor goes without saying that
he's he's just able to notate actors in
ways that are always useful and
sensitive to what the actor is trying to
do
cup the main character is Hillary she's
living with mental health issues growing
up around my mother who was
disintegrating mentally was something I
suppose that formed me
and a lot of those memories have gone
into the way that we render Hillary
it's a very warm portrait of a woman you
know who is really a lost soul but finds
a strange family within the cinema she
has been embraced by this eccentric
bunch
thank goodness you're here because I
need some of this cake
everyone that I've been able to work
with closely has been incredible and
we're all just on a journey just learned
so much from each and every one of them
in different ways the cinnamon love a
bunch of people who don't argue we've
never met you
know I've spent most of my adult
professional life sitting in dark
auditoria of various kinds this is my
home you know and then sitting alone as
an audience member losing myself that
little beam of light is escape you know
I believe that what show me a film
I want to see a film
it's a romance about a love of one
courage for another it's a romance about
a love of this particular World about
the beauty of the idea of Cinema
it's not the size of the screen so much
it's whether you get a jump scare at the
same time as 200 other people or whether
you cry at the same time as 200 people
if we're not going out and congregating
there's probably a commonality that
we're depriving ourselves of
I hope people come and see this film in
that spirit
[Music]